mon gars sont enterré là il faut des
fouilles minutieuses
en 4 jours le mur de mystère qui entoure
la disparition de cette jeune femme n'a
pas cédé d'un pouce une enquête
difficile qui commence ici devant cette
maison face à la gare de Pontcharra
c'est ici qu'un témoin aperçoit pour la
dernière fois Marie-Thérèse bon senti
depuis 5 ans elle distribue des journaux
gratuits entre la Rochette où elle
habite et Pontcharra vers 16h elle
dépose dans le hall une pile de journaux
sa voiture est garée dans l'impasse qui
borde la maison le soir les gendarmes la
trouveront à la même place porte ouverte
le sac à main de la jeune femme et sur
le siège avant depuis le recherche
entreprise par la gendarmerie n'ont rien
donné à partir de la maison de la gare
et dans un rayon de 4 km tous les
terrains ont été méthodiquement fouillés
en vain pour la famille et les proches
de Marie-Thérèse l'hypothèse de la fugue
est invraisemblable
je suis formel et j'en suis sûr et
certain que non on s'était vu le
mercredi après-midi puisque je suis
responsable de la coordination du
journal de la distribution journal on
s'était vu l'après-midi on a passé
l'après-midi ensemble et avec le patron
et on a on a plaisanté un petit peu on
s'est quitté donc le soir parce qu'elle
devait prendre de l'essence avec sa
voiture et on s'y retrouver le soir tout
à fait très bien elle n'aurait pas
laissé son sac avec de l'argent de daim
toutes ces cartes de crédit et bon les
clés sur la voiture la voiture ouverte
la disparition de la jeune femme mère de
deux enfants a profondément ému la
population le maire de La Rochette a
dirigé samedi les recherches entreprises
par des bénévoles la photo de
Marie-Thérèse bonfantie est affichée
dans toutes les rues de Pontcharra la
gendarmerie recueille maintenant tous
les témoignages et les vérifier
scrupuleusement
c'est près de cette maison appelée
maison châtain que Marie-Thérèse
Bonfanti a été vue pour la dernière fois
le 22 mai 1986 pendant qu'elle
distribuait des journaux un an
auparavant presque jour pour jour une
autre jeune femme Marie-Ange Billoux 19
ans avec également disparu pratiquement
au même endroit alors qu'elle devait se
rendre à Chambéry en auto-stop depuis
plus rien des recherches restées vaines
et des dossiers sans réponse hier on
apprenait que Maître Rossetti l'avocat
des familles des deux disparus demandez
la réouverture de l'enquête auprès du
parquet selon cet avocat les recherches
effectuées n'ont pas été suffisantes
notamment en ce qui concerne l'emploi du
temps d'un suspect au lourpassé
d'agression à l'encontre de jeunes
femmes la décision de reprendre
l'enquête dépend à présent de la chambre
d'accusation qui devrait donner sa
réponse au début du mois de mars
il faut des fouilles minutieuses cette
maison est le point central dans
l'affaire des disparus de Pontcharra ici
le 22 mai 86 à 15h30 on a retrouvé la
voiture vide de Marie-Thérèse bonfantie
âgé de 25 ans autre disparition dans la
ville un an plus tôt le 9 mai 85 Marion
Billoux elle a 19 ans les familles de
ces deux jeunes filles font cause
commune pour protester contre la
démolition de cette maison qui selon
elle cacherait les secrets des fouilles
approfondies permettrait peut-être de
trouver des cadavres
vous avez un garage sur notre droite et
ce garage effectivement il y a une fosse
alors cette fois c'est ben ma foi
elle peut peut-être beaucoup parler on
sait pas un peu plus loin de la maison
il y a le problème du rond-point aussi
dites mon plus oui alors ce rond-point
le soir de la disparition
si vous voulez on a fait certaines
recherches et le lendemain on était déjà
après remblayé donc le terrain qui
appartient qui a attenant à la maison
j'ai fait une demande au procureur qui
m'a répondu en me disant que maintenant
l'enquête des close et que je pouvais
normalement faire la démolition de cette
maison sans risquer de gêner l'enquête
s'il faut faire les manifestations tous
les jours puisque le maire nous y a
forcé et qu'il a bouleversé il a osé
bouleverser deux familles deux jours
avant Noël et ben nous ferons nous
continuerons aussi si ils ne veulent pas
nous écouter nous continuerons cet
après-midi demain ce sera le 24 après
demain ce sera le 25 et ainsi de suite
et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à ce que nous en nous ouvre nos
dossiers et jusqu'à ce qu'on ait des
fouilles qui respectent les ossements de
nos enfants
depuis 9 jours maintenant Janine Gonnet
à son domicile de Pontcharra détient des
ossements qui pourraient être ceux de sa
fille Marie-Ange disparue depuis le 9
mai 1985 elle avait 19 ans avec la mère
de Marie-Thérèse 25 ans disparu elle un
an plus tard elle les a recueillis
elles-mêmes lors de la démolition d'une
maison près du passage à niveau la
maison près de laquelle avait été
retrouvée la voiture de Marie-Thérèse
Bonfanti voilà 5 ans et demi le lieu du
crime selon les deux familles alors vous
attendez quoi maintenant
j'attends j'attends que j'attends que
j'attends j'attends que quand même les
services officiels s'occupent de ces
pièces nous disent
d'abord si ce sont des ossements humains
officiellement parce que moi j'essaie
d'une façon officieuse par le
vétérinaire et par le docteur mais je
voudrais que ça soit dit officiellement
les bulldozer maintenant ont fait leur
œuvre le plus extraordinaire dans cette
affaire c'est la solitude des familles
face à cette découverte madame Gonnet
hier est allée elle-même voir un
vétérinaire pour tenter d'identifier ses
ossements puis un médecin pour la
justice la gendarmerie la mairie de
Pontcharra l'enquête éclose depuis belle
lurette s'il s'agit bien doucement
humain on envisagera de la réouvrir en
attendant Janine Gonnet poursuit sa
quête son sac en plastique jaune à la
main
vétérinaire qui a mis ça
peut-être du nouveau après la
disparition de deux jeunes femmes dans
l'Isère en 85 et en 86 après des
semaines d'enquête les recherches
avaient été abandonnées à l'époque et
les dossiers considéré comme clos par
les gendarmes les familles des deux
disparues elles continuent leurs
recherches et il y a une dizaine de
jours la mère de l'une des deux jeunes
filles a découvert dans les sous-sols
d'une maison en cours de démolition à
Pontcharra en Isère donc une semelle de
chaussures et surtout des ossements qui
pourraient être ceux de l'une des deux
victimes enquêtes Anne Mourgues et
Jean-François bec
Janine en est certaine c'est fragments
d'os appartiennent à sa fille Marie-Ange
disparue il y a 6 ans jamais retrouvé en
quête classée ou appartiennent à
Marie-Thérèse une autre jeune femme de
la région disparu un an plus tard jamais
retrouvé enquête classée des fragments
retrouvés sur ce terrain lors de la
démolition d'une maison en présence des
familles juste à côté de l'endroit où
l'on perd la trace des deux jeunes
femmes
on est venue vers le garage qui était là
et dans lequel il y avait une fosse
alors on a demandé donc de creuser dans
cette fosse et c'est à cet endroit là
précisément que l'on a retrouvé des
ossements les familles des disparues en
sont alors persuadés ces indices vont
permettre de relancer l'enquête
et la maison n'y est plus pour nous ils
nous ont tout le temps levés tout enlevé
parce que nous on ne peut plus dire
c'est là qu'il m'a fini disparu mais
l'enquête est toujours close les
familles se sont isolées seules contre
le maire qui Distel a fait niveler le
terrain au risque de faire disparaître
d'autres indices faux rétorque intéressé
chaque fois que les fouilles ont été
menées ont été menées en accord avec les
familles sur indication des familles et
chaque fois que nous avons interrompu
les fouilles sur les recommandations de
la famille
la seule contre les gendarmes qui ont
refusé de prendre les ossements car
l'enquête était fini depuis longtemps
seul contre la justice qui refuse de
rouvrir le dossier pour le procureur on
n'est même pas sûr que les ossements
soient d'origine humaine seul au moins
le temps que les fragments en cours
d'expertise livre leur secret d'après le
procureur si ce sont bien des eaux
humains si ce sont bien des eaux de
femmes si ce sont bien des eaux récents
alors l'affaire des disparus de
Pontcharra comme on l'appelle ici
pourrait peut-être rebondir en 1986
Marie-Thérèse bonfonti 25 ans mère de
deux enfants disparaît ici devant la
maison châtain rasée depuis tout près de
la gare de Pontcharra cet après-midi là
Marie-Thérèse montfenti livre des
journaux
elle sort sa voiture elle laisse les
clés sur le contact et elle ouvre le
coffre prend le paquet et va le déposer
là on est vers 15h30 et elle n'en
sortira plus personne l'a vu sortir ce
qu'on a entendu c'est des témoins un
grand cri des cris aussi intenses ça ne
s'oublie pas 35 ans après l'avocat de la
famille un spécialiste des affaires
classées recherchent toujours la
disparue il a épluché le dossier
d'enquête relevé des failles décider la
justice à tout reprendre à zéro il y a
des gens qui étaient sur place des
locataires des locataires ont déménagé
mais on a pu les relocaliser
donc on va les réentendre un ancien
militaire suspect à l'époque sera lui
aussi entendu à nouveau par les
gendarmes de la section de recherche
35 ans après à quelques centaines de
mètres du lieu de la disparition les
fouilles recommencent les moyens
modernes permettront à ces légionnaires
du génie spécialiste du déminage de
retrouver le corps s'il est enterré
vous savez quand il y a ces toutes ces
fouilles qui sont en train d'être faites
ça va peut-être réveiller certaines
mémoires ça va peut-être travailler
certaines personnes qui savent peut-être
quelque chose qui ne l'ont jamais dit
pour des raisons qui leur appartiennent
mais qui là vont peut-être se sentir 30
ans après avec l'âge avec un peu plus de
raison vont peut-être se dire ben je
vais pas garder ce secret jusqu'au bout
je vais peut-être le dire l'avocat de la
famille espère relier cette affaire à
d'autres en 1984 et 1985 trois autres
jeunes femmes avaient disparu dans les
environs
[Musique]